[Musique]
bonjour anne zakat bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france est les
etats unis avancent en ordre dispersé
certains sont confinés pas d'autres est
ce la bonne méthode selon vous les deux
parce que l'opinion de ton être en
l'occurrence a nui au pays
je pense que effectivement les étalons
passion les états sont bien plus
responsable que le gouvernement en
l'occurrence fédéral
cela montre une fois de plus qu'il est
important de comprendre que
contrairement à d'autres pays très
centralisé aux états unis sur mu et
divers et si partager avec nos cinquante
états que les états devraient avoir plus
de pouvoir dans les habituels vers
fédéral en matière de coordination nous
avons vu que les professionnels qui est
gère les agences telles que par exemple
celle de détection et de prévention des
maladies sont très efficaces dans leur
travail
mais le chef de l'exécutif donald trump
s'est révélé n'être qu'un petit tyran
qui peut être comparé à un aristocrate
français qui n'a aucune place à ce
niveau
hamza gamme comment réagissent tu
aujourd'hui les américains est ce que
l'inquiétude est montée d'un cran de
jour en jour américains ont l'habitude
des crises maintenant car donald trump
s'est révélé à un inventeur de crise au
cours des trois ou quatre dernières
années la plupart des américains
prennent un peu de recul
respire et étudie eux-mêmes ce qu'ils
doivent adopter pour leurs familles
et eux mêmes nous avons vu des crises
dans les magasins et les boutiques
c'est la preuve que les gens pensaient
que la chaîne au visionnement serait
remise en question et qu'il voulait
faire des réserves soit à court terme la
plupart des américains ne se précipite
pas dans les magasins pour acheter
beaucoup de nourriture comme on dit et
dans les médias ce sont des exceptions
beaucoup d'américains se sont organisés
au niveau et privés au niveau caritatif
afin de centre était au niveau du
voisinage afin de maintenir dans le
temps une distance sociale
je pense que en majorité les américains
réagissent de façon très intéressante
cela fait chaud au coeur cela montre que
la nature des américains et que nous
voulons être solidaires en général nous
nous sommes prêts à faire ce qu'il faut
pour la communauté de défis auxquels
nous faisons face bien sûr c'est que le
gouvernement fédéral ne prend pas ses
responsabilités et qu'il n'y a pas
d'idée très claire de quoi faire si on
est contaminée par la maladie
l'administration de donald trump a pris
beaucoup de temps avant de donner sa
formation
aux états et au gouvernement au niveau
local ils n'ont pas expliqué les défis
et les difficultés que représente le
coronavirus et c'est pour cela que nous
avons une hausse du nombre des cas les
américains n'ont pas eu assez de temps
n'ont pas été assez avertis par leurs
gouvernements
cela n'est pas une critique de la
bureaucratie fédérale des agences ou
haute du cdc je critique les mains plein
de donald trump en tant que dirigeant
c'est une fois de plus la preuve qu'ils
devraient le pas à leurs élus et avec un
peu de chance on ne vend que cela ne
sera plus qu'à damas cannes donald trump
prévient qu' un confinement prolongé
pour être tout simplement à détruire le
pays mais existe-t-il d'autres solutions
est ce que le gouvernement américain
parle de d'autres solutions une halte
reims n'a pas encore présenté de plan le
plan clair pour la suite ce qu'il a dit
c'est que nous devons favoriser
l'économie par rapport aux personnes
ordinaires
ce moment à l'échelle de l'histoire
humaine sera très important car il nous
montrera que l'économie ce sont des
chiffres mais que permettre aux gens de
conserver leur maison de conserver leur
famille de mener des vies productives
selon leurs propres mesures et non pas
selon les mesures économiques sera très
important donald trump propose que nous
mettions un terme à la quarantaine et
que nous relancions activité économique
mais c'est stupide pour être pour parler
simplement cela montre qu'il ne comprend
rien aux grands sujets c'est pourquoi
l'administration ne réussit pas à
traiter cette crise de manière efficace
si nous étudions la situation par le
spectre économique alors effectivement
on peut considérer qu'il va y avoir une
récession une baisse de l'activité
économique c'est inévitable mais le
pouvons surmonter cela si elle les
américains les petits propriétaires les
petits employeurs ont la maturité et le
calme nécessaire afin de mener des
actions intelligentes
après la tees tenait à trump à une
solution c'est d'injecter de l'argent
dans le système mais le capitalisme tel
qu'il imagine a détruit la mairie qu'au
cours des dernières années ne sommes
plus les états unis qui ont sauvé la
france lors de la deuxième guerre
mondiale nous ne sommes plus cette
amérique à kia a joué un rôle majeur
dans l'histoire du monde
nous nous sommes obsédés par le petit
profit les entreprises ne sont pas
méchantes en général mais si on lui met
en avant les entreprises et qu'on oublie
les personnes qui vous ont élu alors
cela réduit à néant tout le système
américain
merci beaucoup a indiqué mme d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir sur arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes stratège
démocrate fondateur de the pluralisme
project vous étiez en direct de roggwil
aux états unis merci beaucoup